طيب يعني هذه هذه الصور التي سنعرضها الان
هي عباره عن قذيفه اصابت احد المباني في
الخرطوم لا نعلم حقيقه في اي منطقه ولكن
هي نتيجه للاشتباكات بين الطرفين بين
الجيش السوداني وكذلك قوات الدعم السريع
كما اشار ضيفي واشار مراسلنا يتم احيانا
في منطقه السجانه في الخرطوم كما يقال لي
هذه هي اللحظات قبيله
سقوط هذه القذيفه على المبنى الواقع في
الخلف
واحد المباني في منطقه السجانه كما اشار
مراسلنا في مروي كان هناك اشتباكات
بالاسلحه الخفيفه والاسلحه الثقيله ايضا
في الخرطوم يحدث نفس نفس المشهد لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات